I thanks for coming up to my talk I hope
you had a nice caffeine shot for the
last three to come I think I will talk
to you about why data science in the
medical fields well both kind of sucks
but it's very awesome it rocks at the
same time yeah I think I actually
changed like I changed my title of the
talk like yesterday I think or yeah in
two slides because I first had AI but I
realized when I was making the talk like
actually it applies to data science in
general
so yeah data science in the medical
field and why this well I work in a
medical field and I think it's a well it
has its challenges but also the medical
field because I think it matters to
everybody like who has never been to a
doctor in his life so I guess it matters
to all of you you know it has influences
on how we are treated how medicine works
and how we are being diagnosed and I
think a lot is gonna happen in the in
the coming years so that's also what I'm
gonna share with you what is what is
going on there's a lot of spots back
there still so you can't um yeah so I
think we all we all benefit from this
and I will tell from my experience and
from some people I talked to from data
engineers in the medical field to
companies to doctors but a disclaimer
it's not inclusive or exclusive to only
this field what I'm gonna share with you
so as I'm gonna talk for my own
experience Who am I I study at the
University of Trento technical Medicine
and actually from the time that I did my
first Coursera course with Andrew ng
maybe people know yes Millie of course
yes also my first machine learning
course and definitely not the last
because after that I tried to do all my
internships and projects related to data
science and machine learning
in the medical field so I worked with
for example is anyone recognizes what
this is nice yes
ECG so it's the signal from the heart's
electrical signal on detecting Eretria
but also for example on walking data so
I first made my own prototype with my
own electrodes and stuff but this is a
bit nicer version that I bought and we
were testing with for example
Parkinson's patients because they have
trouble walking and to be able to
quantify the quality of gait or walking
brain signals detector detects epilepsy
seizures and it's a lot of reasons to be
done has been done on it but
unfortunately still so limited yeah
clinics actually use these algorithms
that I think exist yeah more on an EEG
so in brain signals at in Boston on an
internship and there I also used by
torch and oh yeah in my the epilepsy
project I switched that's important from
MATLAB which I got at university to the
bright side - all that changed things
because I think the deep learning and
stuff you have things go a bit quicker
and yeah I never looked back to my left
eye or my last project that's also what
I'm going to tell you more about it's
about cardiac MRI so heart imaging yeah
I use tensor flow Cara's
Google cloud platform and I will use
this as a case study to walk through the
different issues that you can come along
and different challenges within the
medical field doing data science well if
you might have noticed if you look at
all the pictures that came across there
is I think two things that are in common
which is medical field and data science
so that's the her yeah clearly what I
really like doing and I'm not the only
one with respect to medical earning I
guess and also you guys here you might
have seen these pictures before it's
from a Google search you can actually
make I made this myself so you can just
type in some keywords and see how the
search frequency changed over time
well we are here around 2013 and
everything started to boom I think by
date I was what
years ago about here the first rays
yeah but also in a medical field things
are happening
maybe mostly in research and lesson in
practice and I will tell you why why
that's a bit slow maybe which is some
examples this is a histology example so
what we are looking at is when they take
a little bit of tissue out of your organ
so it is in this case the prostate to
see what kind of cancer you have in or
if there's any cancer and this is what
they put on in a microscope to detect
which cells are what and if they're
healthy or not and yeah there's research
going on and automatically detecting
these things because there's
pathologists that look at these samples
the whole day through a drugs drug
industry of course a major industry
where a lot of men of money is invested
in also they're trying to figure out new
structures of molecules that can work
together to have yeah which they hope to
predict if they are effective for
certain kinds of diseases and this one I
think is really cool this is a start-up
in in I'm a huh and what he does it's a
brain computer interface he types with
his brain signals so when he looks at
the screen you see like the letters are
flickering and the brain signals
recognized at which letter he is looking
at with his own flickering pattern so it
recognizes from the signals in the back
of the brain like what pattern he's
focusing on and I tried it with actually
a very smaller headset they are already
having a more compact one and I had a
perfect score it's like it works and oh
you're typing with your brain it's
pretty good yeah and this project like
so this is my project
it's about cardiac function analysis and
about the automatic analysis of these
images because we want to know more
about if your heart is healthy or
nothing and why would we want to know
that well how many of you know someone
with heart problems
yeah heart attacks or arrhythmia
and it's I think cardiology is one of
the biggest departments in a hospital a
lot of heart failure patients exist and
especially in the older range about 65
the frequency actually yeah increases as
well and the MRI so the magnetic
resonance imaging we'll just call it MRI
I think also most people actually know
that term it's the gold standard for
assessing how well your heart is still
pumping the blood through your body and
when you want to know that like how much
blood is being pumped out every bit you
know we need to know something about the
volumes in the heart so what we're
looking at here is a slice through the
heart and this is the right heart
chamber and this oh sorry this is the
left heart chamber even though it's at
the right and this is the right heart
chamber and the left one is usually most
important because that's the one that
actually pumps the blood through your
whole body and the right one does that
through your lungs that's also why the
muscle is a lot thicker there and yeah
that's not the most important one to
function very well and well if you want
to know how much blood is in there we
need to know of course what the area in
here is so what we could do is contort
it and then we know for this slice in
the heart like around about how big is
that well I you know for one slice I did
this in PowerPoint I mean they have some
tools for that but it's doable but what
if you have all your slices so per
patient you usually have around well 8
to 15 depending on the skin and then
what if you also add time to that oh
that quickly adds up shooter yeah to
repeat it
it's going quickly even though it's a
very short movie it adds up to about 400
images for one patient well that's a
quite a lot of work if you want to do
that manually so we wanted to automate
this process of segmenting yeah the
different tissues in the heart
automatically and what they can do with
this is they can evaluate for example
medications so when they have a patient
come in they make a scan and they see
what is the heart function
they give medication and then they can
evaluate okay is it now better is it
better functioning better
also for example pacemaker indication to
be able to get a pacemaker you need
actually to have a certain degree of
having a bad heart and yeah they have to
measure it in some way and to say about
well what your future might be like if
that's gonna be good or bad and that
brings me to the first issue or the
first challenge and I think we've heard
it before
a common one not only in the medical
field but data retrieval where are you
gonna get your data from especially in
the medical field if you want to build
software as a commercial company because
this the hospital is gonna give you the
data is it public well there are some
data sets but usually there is bias and
used it might be yeah not like a very
huge in use sets and also what I heard
from Bowser he's a co-founder of Peck
Matt they are actually a medical
software company he's a lot like either
does not exist or there isn't enough of
it and an example in the back I don't
know if he recognized all these images
but this is actually all the small
images in the back that were the heart
images of one patient so about the 400
images and well we have these 400 images
at this one patients but actually only
about 20 of them were labeled because
it's so difficult and time-consuming to
do they only take the ones that they
think contains most information which is
when the heart is the biggest and when
the heart is the smallest when all the
blood is being pumped out because then
they can look at the difference and say
like hey so much blood has been pumped
out and that is important to know so
also we encountered that problem like
okay we have quite a lot of MRIs but you
know the label set is a lot smaller
already and yeah so I'm not the only one
with that problem but what did we do to
get data and that's collaborate so at
the time of the start of this project I
was an intern at Siemens now I
temporarily work at go data driven it's
a bit complicated but it doesn't matter
the deal is that we were working
together so we had commercial parties
involved but also very importantly
Hospital the umcg Coningham with
professor PIM from the highest who is a
cardiologist and very very enthusiastic
about all the new technologies going on
right now in artificial intelligence and
data science so he was very willing to
support a supportive project and give us
the data and then we also have Google
and Binks who is a Google cloud provider
if I can say it all the way then what
did we do train a network we wants to
make a model so it's not gonna be a very
technical talk if you might have noticed
so this is the most technical is gonna
get I think what we did is we have an
image sample here the MRI and the label
so this is the label for the left
ventricle which is an image the size
same size as the input where every pixel
is either part of the left ventricle or
it's not part of the left ventricle and
from that we used a model based on the
unit we try to actually get an output
that of course looks similar to your
label so we see that here this is the
map with values between 0 & 1 so this is
not binarize Jets like that one yeah and
actually so it's a classifier but it's a
classifier for each pixel so each pixel
gets the class either yes or no part of
the left ventricle and that's why it is
weird shape because it's not just two
classes it needs to become the same
shape as the input and because it looks
like a you it's got a unit easy as that
and we had to train it and we decided to
train it as yeah you saw one of her
collaborators with Google cloud in the
clouds
well if you tell in the medical fields
like hey yeah we're gonna do things with
the cloud
oh really yeah okay but actually by law
it's it's allowed you don't need extra
consent from a patient to put your data
into clouds so even if it's not
anonymized you have to keep it safe of
course but you can do it you don't have
to ask the patient's like oh is it okay
if we put your your scans and in the
cloud so it is allowed and actually what
we see what I see in a lot of startup
business models is
that you that make software in America
industry they actually do use the club
so they sent right for away from the
scan they can send things to the cloud
analyze and return answers so that's
what we did we used it we trained it and
what you get out is of course the
predictions yeah so the results we ash
Indian made three networks for the three
different structures and and we had a
dice index which is like a metric for
similarity it doesn't really matter what
it means but it was for left-hander
comes the easiest it was about 95
percent and the right fence around my
go-kart was a little bit lower about 58
percent well but what does that actually
mean like is that validation yeah anyone
recognises this watch this Wow one one
bridge guys I don't even know if it's
don't TV thanks for the honesty so what
does that even mean I mean if my
algorithm works because it shows 90% of
accuracy then is it a good algorithm I
mean it kind of depends on what data you
use of course and we talked about it
before like is it a very homogenius
small data set that you can over fit too
or is it representable for your whole
population and in this case for us for
example is very important like actually
the data set we have now which is
finally we used MRIs from Philips I was
intern at Siemens but all the data came
from Hirai from Philips but you know
does it also work on a different
machines and also our patients were
infarct patients so they all had a heart
attack but what does it do in healthy
patients so we can have for example a
90% accuracy but yeah what does that
actually mean
and another thing is actually like if
you were to impair it to for example if
you want to make a model to predict who
is missing their flight's or who's going
to miss their flights it's pretty easy
to say well they're on the plane or
they're not there's not really anything
in between
but doctors well they can differ in
their opinions and for example that our
case what you see here is there's this
little bumps I don't know if you see it
yeah with the arrows and these are
little muscles that are attached to your
heart cells and well some say yeah
that's part of the blood volume that's
like ah doesn't matter we can just put
the contours here and I don't say no no
no no no we're muscle is there's no
blood so we have to go around it so you
already got two different answers for
the same question so if I get a 90%
accuracy who do I even compare it to is
that compared to the one radiologist or
the other and well you can imagine
that's asking 10 radiologists to do to
do this for you it's kinda expensive but
this is a real problem in a lot of
medical medical problems because there's
not always one right answer and here's
also the results of what you see here is
the ground truth of the percentage of
Bloods being pumped out at every beat
and these are all the data points and
for different patients yeah and this is
our prediction so if it's longer made a
line of course it would be perfect but I
I was looking at some literature about
what is the integrative variability they
call it so if I would ask 10
radiologists how much would they differ
and it's around 5% and these are these
red lines and my standard error was I
don't know if they're really clear but
the lights gray lights and they're
really close together actually so you
know what does this mean am i perfect
am I just as well as you know one
radiologist or you know yeah when is it
good enough so once you have a model a
model is nothing I mean the model is
nothing unless you can use it so the
next step would be to productionize go
from your model to actually something a
doctor can use because they're not going
to go into tensor flow and say
load MRI that's not gonna happen so you
need some people that can actually do
that yeah but this is a quote from the
professor that we work is and he's like
yeah you know it's just simply easier to
make money in a different industry so
this is about I think this is twofold
it's not only about you know if I want
to make a software product well you
could have second thoughts about you
know going for the medical industry all
the way because it can be a long
trajectory before you get back your
revenue it hurts a bit get back your
investment and you know you might choose
well let's do something a little bit
easier and the second thing is where
would you work there is I think
different industries that are easier to
or are you higher salaries can be gains
then maybe in research or in the
hospital so to get high quality people
on board data engineers data scientists
that can do this so for engineers it's a
thing a bit harder as well this is
actually a quote from our host Bianca
she's data engineer at the Dutch Cancer
Institute and what she said it was like
we lacked a centralized ITV leading to
data silos and I think this yeah it's a
very good demonstration of how complex
the hospital structures are because it's
pretty isolated and financial flows are
complicated and you know there's you're
dependent of subsidies a lot so if they
have this group that we are working
together with this one professor and
he's really enthusiastic and he's
getting all the money in and you know he
hires a PhD to do something for him and
to do data science but yeah then he gets
money for four years for his one PhD
year who is very good at doing data
science but then maybe he wants to build
a product but then maybe he needs a data
engineer a software engineer yeah but
there's no money for that and he is
there for four years so who's gonna
who's gonna do that there's not the
enterpreneur entrepreneurial mindset or
drive that could be there commercially
so I think within the hospital this is
pretty
difficult to to get things going and get
things to really be productionize well I
gave it a try for me actually the same
reason because of contracts they also
bureaucracy in hospitals as a set
complex structure is really difficult I
took a long time before the guys from go
dates are driven and the real technical
guys could join the project and work
with me I kinda have to do it by myself
and yeah I'm not a software engineer but
I try to make some prototype interface
in Python this is it's a PQ t5 you say
that correctly so let me see here is how
the hard flames change so the blue line
is the left ventricle and this is one
heartbeat so you can see here it's
completely filled with blood and then
it's pumped out and it fills again and
the green line is pretty flat which is
good because it's the muscle which
should not disappear during a heartbeat
that's a good thing it's a check you
know then you know that you're not doing
a really stupid things and here are some
some features that doctors look at often
and yeah there's you know it's changes
when you click that I was really proud
of that like yes it works I mean
everybody right when you have this thing
that you actually don't know how it
works and then like but Indians luckily
we got the contracts going and some guys
actually made it more fancy with a web
app so now actually you guys can type in
this and then you can you can choose
some patient number we don't have all of
them until 223 so they don't won't all
work but and it gets the data right from
google cloud and yeah you can pretty
much do the same thing it's not that
much different but it already looks a
lot better um then when you have a
product implementation how do you get it
there where you want to have it and how
mostly how are you going to get it there
because I'm well we've been building on
an app for heart function analysis but
if we look at the position of her
radiologist he's not only looking at
hearts he's also looking at
brings and prostates and livers and so
are they gonna have some sort of app
store and like for every patient they
have to click something else and then
scrolling is once with the errors and
then it's with the mouse and you know I
cannot imagine that's gonna be the best
way to do it or do we need maybe you
notice this little comic do we need one
standards and should we ask Philips for
Siemens she leaned on them to make all
the software and implement that in their
machines but I guess you know it's a big
organization that's damn slow so I don't
know the answer if anyone does please
let me know and because I'm really
thinking about like what is the best way
to you know make this make this work and
and speed up things a bit in the
implementation of all these cool data
science and I research that's being done
in different fields but then you know
it's also implement it in in the medical
field last but not least for sure the
acceptance because doctors well they are
kind of stubborn I don't know if I'm
offending anyone any doctors in the room
which makes sense because they have a
large responsibility if you compare it
to for example a factory worker or
Factory and a manager decides like oh
we're having too many machines breaking
down because of failure bye-bye please
they say ok we're gonna use this
computer vision to and it's gonna detect
when something needs to happen and you
know they just have to deal with it and
if it works or not this manager will be
responsible and he will feel whether
things have gone right or wrong but if a
hospital tells a doctor like hey yes
please we have this cool thing to use it
please and yeah it will it will save his
money then who is responsible when
there's a mistake mistake being made
it's not only the hospital it's a doctor
himself or herself so that it makes
sense I mean it's not it's not good for
his industry but it makes sense they
have a lot of responsibility
they're short yeah this is there's this
suit this was a comment made also by a
medical software company and they have a
seee certified product so it has its has
it's like label and they can sell it but
what they hear lots apparently is like
yeah yeah sure but please let us
validate its first two and then you know
maybe we'll buy it there's just little
trust still in in what's going on and to
invest in it and what to invest in it
there is but to really you know use it
and last like something that is in many
I don't know how my links and at least
comes along all the time with blogs and
stuff like oh yeah the chops of
radiologists are going to disappear well
I was a couple of months ago I talked to
a retired radiologist and I was thinking
like what was radiology like 50 years
ago oh wait
there was no MRI there was no CT well
that changed so I think it's these
comments about technology like Oh
everything's gonna go wrong now it's
just stupid or something if I can say it
that way but you know things are gonna
change
but it always has technology has changed
thing it has made jobs disappear but it
also had created new jobs and
radiologists know these days because of
the things we can do with all these
imaging techniques we use them more I
mean the amount of MRIs being made every
year it's just increasing so we also
need to find a way to make it the
analysis more efficiently so we can
process all this new data that that
comes to us so I think it's just gonna
change but it's not gonna disappear so
for anyone knowing radiologists please
ease their minds
I'm sorry shorts the different issues
that I addressed oh yeah again it can
also definitely address industries you
working data retrieval validation and
certification of your algorithms to
actually productionize it implement it
and to actually have people use it yeah
so as many challenges if they that that
this industry faces
but there's one thing I can tell you
data science is gonna change a lot in
the medical fields it's gonna change the
way we diagnose so for example here we
see someone listening to the heart is it
gonna be a doctor or is it just gonna be
a machine or an algorithm just a
recorder that is gonna say like hey your
heart sounds like arrhythmia yeah and
the way we treat are we gonna trust the
knowledge of this one doctor sitting in
front of you or what you rather have an
algorithm trained on you know all the
experiments in the world and and know
like oh this treatment would probably
work the best for me regarding my
profile and the role of a doctor I think
this is an interesting one who is gonna
be the second opinion it's the doctor
gonna be the second opinion of the
algorithm or is the algorithm gonna be
the second opinion of the doctor maybe
it's gonna it's it's a full it's our
process and we'll see where it's it's
heading I think it's a really a really
interesting yeah industry and I will
stick around and it's hopefully for a
while and try to push this innovation
forward and and yeah try to to improve
healthcare and use data science for it
and I hope I didn't do you motivate you
too much but actually also motivated you
and to maybe come along with me on that
journey because hey challenge is also
fun right so if you actually you're up
for the challenge and working with this
data a little commercial but the best
data science a week we are doing a
hackathon with these datasets we have to
D 3 D 40 data so for everybody something
in different levels sign up is still
open
so yeah this data science week Penton l
and you can still sign up for it thank
you very much
[Applause]
you're using open-source tools all the
time you see any role for open-source in
say the core software that hospitals use
because from what I understand all of
them we have different software stacks
there's no interoperability it's very
hard to get even the data out systems
whereas a lot of the university
hospitals have adjacent say IT training
department at their core business to
sell software or stuff so it seems like
this is such a missed opportunity always
you mean to the to get the the hospitals
more IT ish in open sourcing thanks oh
okay the other way around yeah I think I
I wonder because I think hospitals are
very you know having a see what they
have to also like CD certify its tools
these things are very important I mean
you cannot just give a make die make
software the diagnosis disease and not
have it approved so I guess you need to
you know that's not that doesn't it's
hard to match maybe with open sores and
I think definitely with the larger IT
systems there's so much investment going
into that like the chip soft and you
built that that that's pretty hard but
yeah maybe small thing I mean the
research yeah researchers are using
tensorflow and all these things
obviously yeah like me yeah I don't know
if that's gonna be soon yeah for easy
yeah that's that's a cool thing yeah
there's a lot of libraries on eg
analysis and and thinks definitely yeah
research is a lot easier than when you
want to do it clinically because that
avoids a lot of rules because then you
are still responsible of well is this
good enough or not but it
doesn't have consequences yet so that's
a different thing yeah research a lot
that is happening that's changing
quickly I think yeah thanks for adding
on thanks for the talk very interesting
I was wondering if you could elaborate a
little bit on storing data in the cloud
because like I work for the University
of Maastricht and I also often data from
health care registries information
systems and am I allowed to store that
in the cloud well if you have you have
to consent from the patient right that
you are allowed to have the data works
on a no objection basis so the whole GP
practice could participate
yeah the GP gave permission yeah so the
general practitioner you mean right and
he has on his website declaration that
he participates in scientific research
and people can opt out oh yeah oh that's
difficult I'm not sure about these rules
when because I mean if you give consent
usually about like I'm attending this
research I give consent you can have my
data and use it for research then where
you store it is up to you so you need to
make sure it's safe but whether you keep
it safe on the cloud or keep it safe on
a server that's up to you in this case
like so I assume it's the same thing but
I'm not sure about the opt-out opt-in
well but yeah but also even so even if
they don't give consent for so if it's
consent for clinical purposes a patient
comes in and they have their scans made
because they just need it then also it
can be put on the clouds
so I mean consent is the for the
research purpose but you can store it on
cloud yeah when you just as a storage
thank you very much
because you can't warp a car straight
edges are not going to be straight
anymore but you could do with the heart
I imagine does that work that way to
augment data you mean yeah - like
generate more data instead of just
rotating and flipping it also warps oh
yeah I did that yeah I don't have to
slide in here but I definitely
I warped it yeah I we did augmentation
with some warping with contrast
enhancement cropping yeah definitely so
we increased our size I want amount of
data but augmentation is still a way but
it's not all like yeah
[Applause]